When hundreds of thousands of South Korean soldiers are drafted and...
... forced to face a nuclear North Korea,...
...does anyone have the right to be a conscientious objector?
72% of Korean citizens are against any exemption for conscientious objectors.
"A Korean man has the duty to protect his nation,"...
...said an Association of Korean Veterans member.
However, one government agency disagrees.
The National Human Rights Commission of Korea has proposed...
...that the Ministry of Defense and the National Assembly...
..."find alternate forms of service for conscientious objectors...
...for those who refuse to serve their obligatory military service."
The NHRC is a Presidential body but has no legal powers.
They proposed that "Freedom of conscience is a primary human right...
...which cannot be violated even in the situation of national emergency."
The Korean Defense Minister responded negatively saying,...
..."We respect the recommendation of the NHRC but we will follow it...
...only if the National Assembly establishes a related law."
He suggested that any change should be in the far future.
Interestingly,...
...Korea has signed the United Nations Commission on Human Rights resolution...
...1989 - 1959, which among other things allows the signing country's citizens "to have...
...conscientious objections to military service...
...as a legitimate exercise of the right to freedom of thought,...
...conscience and religion."
Perhaps most surprisingly, South Korea has imprisoned more conscientious objectors...
...than all other countries combined since 1953.